Positive and negative 2.33 is called the critical value of Z for 98% confidence.
And if you remember, positive and negative 1.96 are the critical values of Z for
95% confidence. If you worked your way through lesson 6 and really understood
it, then finding the critical values of Z should be pretty easy for you. But
it's still a pretty difficult conceptual idea. So don't get too discouraged if
you're finding this pretty confusing. I would suggest watching these videos and
pausing them all the time to really think about what I'm saying and writing.
There are also a lot of really important definitions. So you have to remember
what a Z score is, and what the standard deviation is, the sampling
distribution. And you have to remember that the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution is called the standard error. And then you need to be able
to express values of sample means in terms of standard errors away from the
population mean. If you can do all those things and you understand these
concepts, then you'll be fine in this lesson. If not, do go back and review
those videos. And do the problems that's in quizzes. Because that will really
help you.